right are you in the [ __ ] stranger
things I'm in the stranger thing so
let's [ __ ] watch it I'm into peaky
blinders what is that okay I'm wanting
to say this love peaky blinders okay you
hate it yeah yeah you don't like it
yeah oh you're like Irish are you Irish
why do you hate your own weird
that's why don't we see Korean dramas
among people my point is this did my
kungfu is great have you watched their
original kung fu movies no they're
phenomenal
okay this [ __ ] right here yeah every
five minutes oh don't you know me like
this what is it Cecilia what's his name
stealin Murphy Killian Killian Murphy
good actor Oh God oh please what not me
[Laughter]
okay if you were married
oh you know like I swear to God 12 hours
of every [ __ ] five minutes and I just
want a rip [ __ ] scarecrows eyes out I
mean this guy first of all John snow and
Cillian Murphy I'm gonna [ __ ] you babe
how do you know because they're not well
he's married so I would never yeah
they're not in two brown-skinned dude
you're crazy dude that's the whole thing
about when guys and girls make celebrity
like [ __ ] list like girls actually
have a chance at we don't actually have
a shot at knocking a couple off the list
yeah none I know never TV credits then
they think you're wrong I'll pull you
don't know what Natalie Portman likes
you don't know just like there's no
maybe in like I do love and the reason
why I get along with people like Gillian
Anderson or Nigella Gillian Jacobs it's
because it's already out there that
there's that sexual thing it's like you
know a mother father kind of you know
mean like mother-son kind of a
relationship right ready when you meet
people like that I like when I'm on like
Lindsay Price on this new show on there
she's
Merida Curtis Stone she's got kids and
when I first met her there was already
like oh you're my little brother it's
already out there I don't have a [ __ ]
chance with anybody of these Hollywood
time is that why you're trying to make
sure that I believe I can't get it yeah
oh you know what go get it then dude
they have can I at least try no he's
married it's okay you could try it yeah
I could you know marry guys in Hollywood
won't do anything weird good point
anyway can if she lets you watch I feel
like you would want him in some way in
some capacity yeah what if you could
like have a threesome with Killian
Murphy you would not have a threesome
with me Bobby
yeah but Hall yeah yeah try eating but
one time I would like pretend that I was
like a part of like you know Ra's al
Ghul's yeah you I'd am a roleplay Dark
Knight kind of a thing you'd roll
somehow you know I'd start with Killian
Murphy yeah I'm gonna get yeah I do a
little storyline you know like scarecrow
killed you know
Bane and I'm Ben's brother so I'm gonna
eat his butthole right because I have a
poison in my mouth yeah I love it
no one's ever talked about eating
[Music]